it's an incredible case here it's been
called the greatest incidence of
travesty of a case of justice and in
travesty in this country for many years
and she has now walked free Kathleen
fulbig she had been found guilty and
held in prison over the last 20 years
for the deaths of three children and in
the fourth case a man slaughter charge
but she had exhausted all avenues of
appeal including another inquiry and
then in the second inquiry using
scientific evidence it found that two of
the children had a genetic mutation that
she carried a third also appears to have
a genetic variation and in the case of
those three children then the fourth
case really fell away because the
prosecution there had used the argument
of
uh they had had used an argument of uh
coincidence and the judge said that that
no longer stood up so really quite an
extraordinary case here pardoned from
prison but the case has not been quashed
at this stage it will still have to go
through a criminal court proceeding
there but a lot of people are comparing
it to the Lindy Chamberlain case that
many people may remember that was when
an Australian woman was held in prison
for around about five years she was
accused of killing her child and it
turned out that it was later a dingo
that took that child from a tent so all
sorts of calls now for this woman to
receive compensation and quite an
outstanding case and a lot of shock here
in Australia today